the other thing you notice when you take
a little time off is how unbelievably
stupid most of the debates you see on
television are this is so funny he's
been fired for three days and he wants
to act like the biggest critic of the
way that television is produced
his Network and his the programs he's
been on for for decades at this point
quite frankly
are the reason why we don't get
substantive debates on for-profit
television we don't get substantive
discussions it's because you've got a
cram in a four minute interview
in between commercials and Lindsey
Graham crying about something like he's
the it's it's not an incorrect diagnosis
but he's the one who caused the illness
in the first place to a great degree